foreign
[Music]
and I'm the director of data science at
pcctc a clinical research organization
facilitating clinical trials in the
cancer space
I used to be an academic and when I was
transitioning to Industry roles I found
challenges in refactoring my resume and
professional portfolio to align with
industry standards I hope to share some
resources that you'll find useful in
this talk what they forgot to teach you
about industry transitions from Academia
or more simply
WTF aita
if you're not familiar with these two
acronyms we'll consider each in turn
first if in the context of your job
you've ever asked what the [ __ ] I'd
probably respond with great question
particularly if you're an academic
this plot shows one aspect of what the
fury in Academia the increasing number
of phds awarded versus the much smaller
number of faculty jobs available
the gap between these two diverging
numbers has helpful been helpfully been
labeled WTF
there are lots of other reasons one
might ask what the [ __ ] in Academia but
this is not really a talk about that I
would instead refer you to the so-called
quitlet where people have discussed
their thoughts and experiences on
leaving Academia in a variety of formats
such as blogs and social media posts
indeed Academia can be a highly
rewarding career if it's what you want
and this talk is not at all focused on
criticizing that career choice
all the same many academics are
currently interested curious and I hope
that many who are not in Academia will
still find useful content in this talk
academics certainly don't hold a
monopoly on asking what the [ __ ]
the second acronym aita stands for am I
the Apple
this happens a lot when academics first
apply to Industry roles as a specific
example I was asking this question when
my first job applications to Industry
industry roles receive no response I
thought am I not qualified are they the
Apple
am I the people
in this talk we'll focus on three common
ways that academics can unintentionally
be the evil
first resumes that are way too long are
common
second cover letters should not be a
thesis on the direction of your research
rather a clear and focused statement of
your value that is aesthetically
streamlined
and last an untidy coding portfolio can
make it very difficult to see how the
first two items come together to make
you amazing
in short avoiding tollery really means
not asking others to work hard to
discover how awesome you really are
as a current reviewer of many
application packages I see some truly
excellent excellent candidates who could
shine that much brighter with some
finesse
fortunately the r Community has created
resources which make each of the three
problems easily solvable
first
let's look at resumes
here quite embarrassingly is the 22-page
resume that I sent as it is to the first
industry roles to which I applied
this Beast served me well in Academia
where CVS are required to be formatted
like this in Industry however yes I was
the [ __ ]
here on the other hand is a stellar
resume that I received about a year ago
from someone a lot of you probably
recognized this conf Shannon palegi this
elegant elegant two-pager gives me an
easily accessible view of Shannon's
skills experience and clear links to her
portfolio a topic that we'll discuss
later
I'm lucky enough to work with Shannon
now and she gave me permission to use
this as an example
the same goes for any examples I'll show
in this talk I either have permission
from the content owner or it's publicly
available
if you want your resume to look like
Shannon's fortunately there is an r
package for that
it's called Data driven CV
I won't repeat any of the how-to content
that the package author Nick Strayer has
carefully assembled if you go to the
package vignette you should be up and
running in under an hour
aside from making a resume that looks
really slick there's a big bonus with
using a package like this that I want to
mention when hiring managers like myself
fit a stack of 50 to 100 resumes I can
recognize right away those applicants
that use R to create their materials
this sends a signal that you're excited
about integrating r-based workflows into
all of your activities not just those
that involve statistics or data analysis
and it's a sure thing that I'll read
those resumes carefully
something else that the data driven CD
package does that's nice is that it
makes it easy to include or omit
information for long or short versions
of your resume
for instance if you still need a long
academic variation for some purposes you
can render with all the Publications in
fluff into dozens of pages and then if
you want the industry ready two-pager a
quick filter within data-driven CV will
get you there
this eases some of the pain I experience
in moving the currency Academia pages
and pages of Publications to a single
bullet point in my resume
next let's discuss cover letters
much like my horrific academic CV I was
also sending out this dense research
statement as a generic cover letter
here instead is a template which is easy
on the eyes through generous use of
white space is succinct at one page and
even makes use of bullet points to
highlight key ideas
recall the signal sending I mentioned
about resumes clearly built with r the
same is true here I right away recognize
this is our markdown or late Tech
rendered due to general font and
Alignment structure a dead giveaway is
the appearance of awesome font icons in
the top right that typically doesn't
happen by accident in a word doc
if you want to render letters like this
here's the Steve templates r package
from Stephen V Miller
making one of these is as easy as
installing the package and creating a
new markdown file from template in the
rstudio menu
but cover letters aren't the only thing
you're allowed to send as part of your
application package
let's have a look at something really
cool in the category that I'll call
cover accessories
in a recent rstudio data science hangout
which is an awesome community resource
that I'll describe later I met Javier
oraca
he described his recent application to
bloom reach in which he went way above
and beyond and made a bloom reach shiny
app with some simulated data that is
themed with their org's color scheme and
logo
the bloom Reach team was of course
totally blown away and Javier landed the
job
this technique of demonstrating what's
possible with shiny as a business
intelligence tool along with his Mastery
of developing in it was spot on
if you're interested in the circus the
secret sauce here
packages used inside of shiny BS lib and
thematic I'll mention that if you're not
a shiny developer and the idea of
integrating these components into shiny
isn't something you want to tackle right
now don't forget that you can use these
same principles namely organizational
theming and showcasing your R skills
within a standard R markdown document
that is rendered to HTML or PDF
portfolios
here's a common look for an academic
coding portfolio and yes this page is
intentionally left blank
Academia doesn't incentivize maintaining
this sort of thing but it's hugely
helpful in showcasing your technical
skills for industry employers I'm going
to show three levels of portfolios with
increasing complexity only one is really
necessary but it's certainly possible to
have all three
first not only is github.com the
standard place to deposit your projects
and code for public viewing the site
also allows you to put together a
personal profile on your landing page
here's a great example for Monica Powell
and her link here shows you how to
create this using the GitHub interface
here though we're gonna see how you can
do it in our studio
conveniently it's just three lines of
code the steps are this created in our
studio project
with the same name as your user your
GitHub user ID
connected to GitHub and create an R
markdown document that renders to GitHub
compliant markdown again these three
lines have used this code achieve these
three tasks directly
mash the knit button in rstudio push to
GitHub and you're done
any modifications you'd like to make are
just done with our markdown syntax that
you probably already know
standard R plots and all the bells and
whistles work here as a super basic
example here's what happened when I
simply rendered the use this rmd default
document through this method and pushed
it to my GitHub repository named my user
id t gerky
cool right
while we're on the topic of GitHub I
want to emphasize that you should use
and organize your pinned repositories
that appear at the top of your page
if you've done a solid job on the resume
and cover materials that we discussed
it's a virtual lock that your GitHub
profile will be looked at put good code
that you're proud of there if it doesn't
yet have good documentation or comments
add them now
yes the very careful reader might be
able to tell that you added the map to
the fact but I claim that this is not a
big deal adding them will show that you
understand the importance of
well-documented code and that you can
produce it
taking this all up a notch here's our
friend Hadley's landing page at his
website
looks awesome
the great news is that you too can be
Hadley
this is made with Sean carras's
excellent postcard package postcards
package
Hadley used the trestles template but
there are other great looking options
here if you want to Branch out a bit
getting started is made very easy with
the help of the package vignette which
is linked here
now here in expert mode you can develop
a full-blown website with a Blog using
rstudio like Allison Hill has been doing
elegantly for years now
her most recent iteration uses Hugo
apparel through blog down which she will
carefully walk you through in detail in
the linked recording of her R ladies
talk from last year
blog down with Hugo is one way to do it
but other popular options include
distill and quarto Danielle Navarro has
superb examples of both in the form of a
quarto Blog that was migrated from
distill
she describes each of those formats and
how you develop in each at her blog post
which is linked here
when it comes time to publish your
content on the web don't forget that you
can use free services from GitHub pages
and netlify there's no need to purchase
the dedicated domain name if you're not
ready for that yet
overlaying all the topics we've
discussed is the incredible R community
if you ever need support want to
discover who is hiring or generally get
connected with amazing people here are
some directions I would suggest I'll
link from this page
in order
Rachel Dempsey runs a virtual weekly
rstudio data science hangout with data
science leaders and community members
this informal get together is an
excellent way to stay in touch and find
out what's new in the r and data science
world
tidy Tuesday is both a podcast run by
John Harmon and a highly engaged weekly
Community activity run by Thomas mock
it's a great way to hone your skills
show off your data science Wizardry and
learn from others
tidy Tuesday is just one component of a
larger very active R for data science
community
this community runs a slack server where
you can ask and answer technical
questions or just chat about data
science in general one very helpful
Channel there is a jobs hiring board
where you'll see many are specific jobs
posted
our user groups or so-called rugs can be
found nearly anywhere in the world these
days if there isn't one close to you
consider starting one the our Consortium
sponsors many of these and will help you
get started back when I was in Tampa I
started one of these which met monthly
and I met friends which I'm very close
with to this day
many job-related connections tend to
happen at these events as well
in the same vein Our Ladies Global is a
worldwide organization that promotes
diversity in our community much like the
rug meetups you can probably find one of
these running in your area and you
should definitely check it out
lastly the rcd community has forums and
job boards that range from the technical
to community building and is a great
place to hang out
the final resource I'm going to leave
you with is a compilation of all the
resources we've discussed and more
WTF aita.com is a place where you can
find these slides and links to the tools
therein
but this talk certainly only represents
a slice of a much larger set of guidance
and resources around industry job
seeking many of you in the RCU Community
have already traveled this road and if
there are things you'd like to see
represented on the site please do feel
free to submit an issue or a pull
request at the GitHub repository
it's my intent that the site organically
grow as a community-owned utility over
time
with that crowdsourcing request in mind
I'll now hand the discussion off to the
excellent R Studio community
thanks so much for having me a conf and
I look forward to seeing the Discord
hallways and answering any questions
that you may have in this particular
session
thank you